hey everybody it's Mike frieden with
on-call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week this week we're talking about cmfc
control
mp.l2-3.8.7 control the use of removable
media on system components you're like
16 videos in today and it's me versus
the camera that's how bad it is
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 800171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so as we look at this control I have
to tell you it's often misinterpreted on
the first read the thought is that you
must restrict computers from being able
to access things like a USB device
without some kind of permission
elevation but that's just not what this
is all about what this control is about
is gaining control or at least
demonstrating that you can control
removable device access the
you should do this is I'll go over in a
moment but But ultimately to me it's an
odd control because it really does not
go deep enough to determine what the
behavior is that the assessors are
really after here ultimately to
understand more let's dive into what the
assessors are looking for and an example
answer that will reveal the true answers
we are all looking for like what is the
meaning of life or what will really make
the assessors happy
let's jump in all right determine if the
use of removable media on system
components is controlled this is
implemented removable media is
controlled via endpoint management
solution all removal media is sanitized
upon insertion in a system device prior
to information access the organization
has the capability of controlling
removable media access via Group Policy
where it is appropriate and
if you are trying to figure out this
control or any other control you're
banging your head against the wall and
you're jumping up and down and you're
like oh my God check out this awesome
video on YouTube that I just found that
solves my problem guess what I can solve
a whole lot more of your problems like
109 more of your problems because in
on-call we work with defense contractors
just like you who have had this D fars
nist itar and cmmc compliant stuff
dropped in their laps like a seagull on
a sunny day we teach you how to level up
and be a proper on-call compliance hero
for your company eliminating gaps great
areas and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
as your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit cmmccompliance
secrets.com or check out the bio below
for links to get help right now if you
love the content we're putting out there
for you help us out with a big thumbs up
on that like button or even better smash
that subscribe button and get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance starts roll it out until the
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure there hit us in the comments
below to let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one foreign
[Music]
foreign